let's face it one of the worst things
about adulting is having the clean if we
can get out of it in any way we'll do it
and since machines are made to make our
lives easier it makes sense we want a
machine made to clean but in sci-fi we
want to go one further we want a robot
to do it for us in fact the first time
the word robot was even used was way
back in 1920 in a Czech play called
Rossum's Universal robots which was
about yep
you guessed it robotic maids and butlers
the robots Rebell but that's a story for
another time
the important thing is what was once
just the play is now pretty close to
becoming reality let's find out how the
science fiction inspired science reality
[Music]
sci-fi has long imagined a future with
robots but has often portrayed them as
one-dimensional fully good or fully evil
early sci-fi robots sometimes tried to
destroy humanity but often they were
helpful assistants doing menial chores
for humans topics a buddy
leave it to Robin he's the big household
help all right
like Rosie The Jetsons family's
housekeeper who cooked cleaned and
helped the kids with homework most homes
today don't yet have robot Butler's but
in 2002 robotics company iRobot
introduced the Roomba a robotic vacuum
that could automatically clean floors
call an angle PO founder of iRobot sites
Rosie the robot as an inspiration for
the Roomba saying people kept asking
when do I get it Rosie she had a huge
influence on the industry thanks Rosie
robots that move more like animals or
humans have long been in development
some even exceed human abilities like
that Boston Dynamics robots can open
doors carry heavy objects and do parkour
sci-fi has also imagined artificial
intelligence inside machines that can
think and problem-solve at a human-like
level one of the first complex sci-fi
portrayals of AI is in 2001 a Space
Odyssey co-written by arthur c clarke
and director Stanley Kubrick Marvin
Minsky an early AI researcher at MIT
advise Kubrick on the depiction of AI
computer how nine thousand how nine
thousand could speak dreamer
play chess Bishop takes Knight spawn and
make plants open the pod bay doors help
deadly plans I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I
can't do that today many of us have AI
in our homes in the form of assistants
Alexa and Siri which are friendly we
hope but as helpful as AI might become
it stops short of processing human
idiosyncrasies and emotion an issue
illustrated in sci-fi by Star Trek's
Android data you told a joke yes I am
not laughing yes perhaps the joke was
not funny no the joke was funny it's you
data so Rosie led to Roomba and now we
have Alexa with innovative jumps like
that it's hard to imagine where robots
and AI go from here in sci-fi
it may be revolution robots take over
the world yes and the revolution is set
for a week from Saturday but in reality
it's whatever we have the creativity to
program for now stop procrastinating and
go and do the laundry it's not going to
wash itself yet
you
[Music]
[Music]